well speaking of present to you and
Michael you'll share a birthday which I
did not know and you always have 25 on
us right now 25 years
um 25th 25 years difference I have to
remind people yeah and I've been
together for like 20 25 yeah married 22.
yeah so yeah so 25 out there we uh
[Applause]
well you know what he's been working
like every hour that God gave but it
just happened to coincide that the week
of our birthday he had five days off so
um it was like what are we gonna do for
the five days and we both left Golf and
I was like I really want to play golf
I'm not going to go somewhere fabulous
and so he can't he mentioned a few
places I'm going through your choice
darling your choice you're working your
choice and then he said you want to go
to Morocco don't you I went yeah
anyway okay so we bucket it to Morocco
and we had a five days a wonderful time
it was wonderful but you know what it's
really interesting because when you
share the same birthday when we were
dating it was the coolest thing ever
yeah I get 10 years on I said I guess a
little pissy about it
you know I'm like first of all it's like
where am I gonna buy him first of all
it's like and then he said anyway but we
always have fun I mean yeah and we had
to presented this this year together oh
that's that's lovely
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]